regrouper en un seul lieu des
professionnels de la santé capable de
prendre en charge les patients durant
les heures de fermeture des cabinets
médicaux de ville une idée portée au
début des années 2000 par l'amicale des
médecins des trois villages de montigny
le bretonneux de 2012 dix ans après son
ouverture la maison médicale de garde
veille sur 233 milles habitants de saint
cyr l'école à magny les hameaux
en passant par l encours sains grâce à
40 médecins généralistes volontaires
on avait une préoccupation éthique qui
était celle de pouvoir rendre service à
nos patients c'est à dire qu'on avait
une vision de ce que pouvait être la
permanence de soins
à une certaine époque il n'y a pas loin
de 10 12 ans ont travaillé trente six
heures d'affilée quoi je veux dire
aujourd'hui ça paraît complètement fou
mais c'est quand même ce qui s'est passé
et de sa part et c'est normal tout le
temps à l'occasion de la soirée
d'anniversaire de la maison médicale
nicolas abou ancien médecin maire de la
ville en fonction à l'époque a rappelé
ce qu'il l'a poussé à mettre à
disposition des locaux de sa commune
c'était un peu moderne parce que on
avait tendance à dire mais les médecins
ils n'ont qu'à se débrouiller
non la santé publique ça relève des
politiques
et comme l'état n'assume est plus
totalement véritablement ce dimension il
était important que les collectivités
locales se prennent en main pour
répondre à ce problème de garde qui
devenait vraiment extrêmement dangereux
reste que cette réussite suscite des
convoitises la maison médicale pourrait
se voir imposer par l' agence régionale
de santé de couvrir un territoire encore
plus vaste les médecins se disent
inquiets les élus partagent leurs
craintes
et si on rajoute de nouveaux patients je
crois que l'on va retomber dans les
problèmes qui sont générés aujourd'hui
au niveau des urgences hospitalières
dont je n'ai pas envie que ça se passe
comme ça
la maison médicale est installé à
proximité de la police municipale les
patients ne peuvent accéder qu'après un
appel auprès du 15